[Musik]
ich bin gefangen in Gaza
vielleicht für immer
Gaza eines der am dichtesten besiedelten
Gebiete der Welt zwischen Ägypten und
Israel
palästinensisches Autonomiegebiet
kontrolliert von der radikal
islamistischen Terrororganisation Hamas
seit 15 Jahren herrschen die Islamisten
hier mit harter Hand und Gewalt
grundlage ist die Scharia das islamische
Recht interpretiert aus dem Koran extrem
frauenfeindlich
mein Name ist afaf alnasha ich bin 19
und ich studiere englische Literatur in
der Islamischen Universität
warum ich so laut und offen über all das
spreche weil ich nicht will dass das
Unglück was mir wieder fahren ist
irgendeinem anderen Mädchen passiert
wollte Kommunikation Studieren im
Ausland ein voll finanziertes Stipendium
in der Türkei im November dann steht sie
am Grenzübergang im Süden von Gaza an
der Grenze zu Ägypten nur raus darf sie
nicht mein Vater hat mir ein Reiseverbot
erteilt
afafs Vater nutzt ein neues Gesetz der
Hamas ein männlicher Verwandter kann
jederzeit mit einem Antrag vor Gericht
die Ausreise einer Frau verhindern wenn
durch die Reise ein absoluter Schaden
entstehe
[Musik]
ganz ehrlich wenn es um studieren geht
gibt es doch keinen Schaden es ist doch
mein Recht selber zu wählen was ich aus
meinem Leben mache es ist doch meine
Karriere die mir niemand anders geben
kann
deshalb bin ich auch nicht sauer auf
meinen Vater sondern auf die Gesetze die
dafür verantwortlich sind
dabei corsing all of this Nachfrage bei
denen die die Gesetze verantworten
besuchen Büro der islamistischen Hamas
in Gaza Stadt
wir haben das palästinensische Gesetz
dort sind Frau und Mann gleichberechtigt
nur das Personen und Familienrecht ist
nach der Scharia gestaltet ein Familien
oder Frauen einen höheren Wert haben
[Musik]
das hat etwas zu tun mit der sozialen
Vision der Palästinenser
palästiniens
eine Vision die wenig zu tun hat mit
einer gleichberechtigten Gesellschaft
fest steht nur 14 Prozent der Frauen
arbeiten obwohl mehr Frauen ein
Hochschulabschluss haben als Männer im
öffentlichen Leben dominieren Männer das
Straßenbild eine patriarchale
Gesellschaft
Frauenverband im Haushalt am Herd zum
Kinderkriegen die Geburtenrate in Gaza
gehört zu den höchsten in der arabischen
Welt
[Musik]
ich bin Zena und ich bin im Widerstand
ich habe meine ganz eigene Vorstellung
über meine Gesellschaft mich macht das
so wütend dass ihr Frauen nicht
respektiert werden aber Wut bringt einem
nichts man muss aktiv werden gegen die
Diskriminierung Vorgehen das tue ich mit
meiner Arbeit
sein ab algunami ist Anwältin die die
sonst keine Rechte haben Kinder und
Frauen vertritt sie nach jahrelangen
Kampf wird senab auch vom Scharia
Gerichtshof akzeptiert sogar als einzige
Anwältin in Gaza so sagt sie ohne Job
ohne Kopftuch das sei ihr wichtig weil
sie nur ohne Kopftuch ihre Resistenz
gegen ein System zeigen könne dass ich
nur verändern kann wenn Gesetzgebung von
Religion getrennt wird
zu tragen bedeutet die Situation zu
akzeptieren es gibt hier Menschen die
tragen Hijab weil sie sich aus sozialem
Druck heraus dazu verpflichtet fühlen
erneute Nachfrage bei der Hammers
hat etwas mit der Kultur zu tun es ist
die eigene Entscheidung die Job zu
tragen oder auch nicht
aber ist das eine freie Entscheidung
natürlich es gibt nur eine Ausnahme wenn
der Arbeitgeber spezielle Kleidung
fordert das hat nichts zu tun mit
Religion auch im Krankenhaus oder auf
dem Feld trägt man eine bestimmte
Uniform
Uniform ein religiöses Symbol als
Uniform die Hamas hat in den vergangenen
Jahren mit gezielten Kampagnen
Schülerinnen und Studentinnen
aufgefordert zu tragen
viele Bildungsinstitutionen dürfen
ohnehin nur von Frauen mit Kopftuch
betreten werden
was hält die junge Frau die so gerne im
Ausland studieren wollte davon
[Musik]
in der Islamischen Universität da gibt
es diese Regel Hijab zu tragen okay ich
respektiere das aber ist das nötig
Frauen in der unijab tragen zu lassen
und draußen ziehen Sie ihn wieder ab
genau zeigen
besuchen einen Modeladen was trägt frau
in Gaza unter dem langen Mantel
jeder Stil
UPS oder
[Applaus]
sowas Leder
westliches Design und religiöse
Kleiderordnung kein Widerspruch
es ist doch keine Schande so etwas
anzuziehen es geht nur darum den
richtigen Moment und Ort zu finden
der richtige Moment für Erft wieder so
eine Heuchelei die wenig zu tun hat mit
persönlicher Entfaltung
wenn ich Hosen trage und auf die Straße
gehe auch wenn drei Menschen in diese
Hose passen bekomme ich böse Kommentare
von der Verwandtschaft
was für Kommentare oh
you using oh du solltest das nicht
tragen so was gemeine Dinge du versuchst
auszusehen wie die im Westen und ich
entgegne dann nein ich will nicht
aussehen wie westliche Menschen
zu mir versuchst du mit der Hose wie ein
Mann auszusehen ich war so nicht dein
Ernst siehst du nicht meinen Kopftuch
sie wird trotzdem weiter Hose tragen und
für ihre Rechte einstehen sie wolle sich
nicht alles gefallen lassen auch wenn
das anstrengend sei
[Musik]
jetzt könnte es ist sehr schwer hier
wirklich ich zu sein ich muss immer
sicherstellen dass ich mich richtig
verhalte dass ich nicht das Falsche sage
wenn andere dabei sind das ist sehr
stressig ich kann nicht spontan sein ich
kann nicht so sein wie ich bin weil
jeder Urteil du bist eben ein Mädchen du
kannst nicht so lachen du kannst nicht
so laufen und du kannst das so und so
nicht sagen
muss in Gaza bleiben sie muss hier
weiter studieren sie hofft darauf dass
sie mehr Rechte bekommt aber sie ahnt
dass ihre Hoffnung ein Traum bleiben
wird